sevgili
denizlililer Öncelikle hepiniz hoş
geldiniz şu anda bir radyo yayını
dinliyor olabilirdin ve bir radyo yayını
dinliyor olsaydınız Belki de beni
tanımayanlar hayal edeceklerdi
diyeceklerdi ki acaba kısa boylu mu uzun
boylu mu acaba mı esmer mi acaba Kilolu
mu zayıf mı şimdi radyo aslında bir
hayal dünyası sizin hayallerinizi
ufkunuzu genişletiyor beni tanımayanlar
hayal edecekler diyecekler ki acaba
oturuyor mu ayakta mı yapıyor bu
konuşmayı nereye bakıyor ne yapıyor
nasıl duruyor Şu an bir şeyler anlatıyor
ama mesela Sahnenin gerisinde tam olarak
nerede duruyor İşte Radyo böyle bir
hayal dünyası ufkunuzu
genişletiyor ama şimdi artık
görüyorsunuz Hepiniz hoş geldiniz bir
kez daha E böyle bir giriş yapmak
istememin sebebi şuydu
Radyo dinliyorsunuz diye tahmin ediyorum
Radyo dinleyenler genelde tanımadıkları
zaman hayal kuruyorlar şimdi benden önce
daha çok dijitalleşme üzerine bir
konuşma dinlediniz ben oraya geleceğim
yani geleceğe de geleceğim ama sizi önce
biraz eski yıllara götüreceğim Hatta
1800'lerin sonlarına götüreceğim öyle
söyleyeyim yani radyonun ilk icadı
dönemi işte marconi bahsedilir radyonun
icadı mucidi Daha doğrusu marconi Tesla
daha sonra yine benzer şekilde
çalışmalar yapmıştır ama radyo ilk
olarak ne zaman yayın hayatına başladı
diye bakacak olursak radyonun ilk yayın
hayatına başlayışı 1900'lerde yani
1800'lerin sonları ve 1900'lerin başı
şimdi o dönem için böyle bir dijital
dünyada yaşamadığımız düşünelim insanlar
birbirlerinden haber alamıyorlar Radyo
ilk olarak bir müzik yayını yapıyor
Amerika'da başlayan bir yayın var Daha
sonrasında Radyo özellikle Propaganda
aracı olarak kullanılıyor şöyle düşünün
Savaş yılları ülkeler savaşıyor ve kimse
kolay kolay haber alamıyor
birbirinden o dönemde radyoyu bir
Propaganda aracı olarak kullanmayı akıl
eden yönetimler oluyor şimdi neden
Propaganda aracı diyorum Çünkü sebebi şu
her zaman doğru bilgiyi gerçek bilgiyi o
dönemde ulaştırmış önemli olan şu
savaşta mesela Almanya ne yapıyor
vatandaşına diyor ki şu anda Bizim
zaferimiz de sonuçlanıyor bizim
ordularımız şu anda Muzaffer oluyorlar
Dolayısıyla Radyo ilk yıllarında tamamen
bir Propaganda aracı olarak kullanılıyor
insanlar radyonun başına geçip haber
almaya çalışıyorlar ülkemizde ne oluyor
savaş ne durumda Ekonomi ne durumda işte
radyoyu o dönemde devletler yöneticiler
ve tabii ki siyasiler keşfetmeye
başlıyorlar Daha sonrasında şu
düşünülüyor acaba Radyo bir eğlence
aracı olabilir mi yani sadece bilgi
vermenin ötesinde bir eğlence aracı
olabilir mi derken müzikli yayınlar
başlıyor radyoda hepinizin şu anda
tahmin ettiği ve bildiği yayınlar olduğu
üzere müzikli yayınlarla beraber derken
bunun ardından mizah ve eğlence
programları başlıyor radyonun birkaç
amacı vardı ilk yıllarda Propaganda ha
hala devam etmiyor mu ediyor Bir diğer
amacı eğlendirme halen devam ediyor
zaten radyonun eğlendirme amacı ve bir
diğer amacı da
bilgilendirme şimdi o yılları şöyle bir
geride bırakacak olursak yine biraz daha
yakın geçmişe g imizde karşımıza şöyle
bir şey çıkıyor sosyal medyanın olmadığı
bir alan düşünün bilgiyi nereden
alacaksınız radyodan ya da televizyondan
televizyonun olmadığı yılları düşünün
yine bilgi size radyodan ulaşacak Radyo
o dönem için aslında geçmiş yıllardan
bahsediyorum hız demekti radyonun hızı
televizyondan çok daha yüksekti Çünkü
televizyonda yayına girmek bir süreç
gerektiriyor ama radyo için böyle değil
mikrofonu düğmesine anda yayındasın
radyonun böyle bir farkı var aynı
zamanda Radyo biraz daha kişiseldir
Radyo biraz daha dosttur size yakındır
ve radyoyu dinlemek için Ekstra bir emek
sarf etmenize gerek olmaz televizyon
için televizyonun karşısına oturmanız
lazım izliyor olmanız lazım Evet şu anda
elimizde sosyal medya var Bir yandan
telefona bakabiliyoruz ama televizyon
izlenir Radyo dinlenir yani radyoyu
aslında yaparken dinleyebilirsiniz Araba
kullanırken dinleyebilirsiniz evinizde
Duş alırken dinleyebilirsiniz yani Radyo
her alanda sizin yanınızda olabilir ve
Radyo
dosttur Şimdi Bütün bunlardan hareketle
bugüne
geldiğimizde şu hep konuşuldu acaba
radyoculuk ölür mü ilk bu konuşma ne
zaman çıktı söyleyeyim tahmin edersiniz
televizyon yayın hayatına başladı ve
sonra dendi ki acaba radyoculuk ölür mü
ve gördüğünüz gibi radyoculuk ölmedi E
şu anda çok detaylarla sizi boğmak
istemiyorum ama Türkiye'de kaç tane
Radyo olduğunu tahmin edebilir misiniz
var mı Bir
tahmin bir şey yok burada bir yarışma
yapmıyoruz sınava tabi tutmuyoruz O
yüzden söyleyebilirsiniz kaç var 500 e
1000 1000'in Üstünde 1000'in üstünde
1200 1300 civarında Türkiye'de radyo var
demek ki radyoculuk ölmüş mü ölmemiş
neden Çünkü ticari bir işletme Demek ki
bir gelir elde edebiliyor Peki radyo
şekil değiştirmeye başladı mı Evet
aslına bakarsanız sosyal medya çıktıktan
sonra internet çıktıktan sonra hep şu
söylendi dendi ki yine Radyo gidiyor
galiba insanlar işte YouTube'a başka
kanallara önlenmeye başladılar Hayır
Radyo yine gitmedi aksine bizim size
ulaşabilme alanımız çoğaldı Biz eskiden
bir radyo cihazı üzerinden size ulaşıyor
Ken son yıllarda uydu üzerinden çeşitli
platformlar üzerinden çeşitli
uygulamalar üzerinden internetten
uygulamalardan birçok yerden ulaşmaya
başladık ha yine de şunu söyleyeyim size
son gelen araştırmalar gösteriyor ki her
ne kadar internet üzerinde dinlenmede
bir artış olsa da genel olarak insanlar
araçlarında arabada veya evlerinde iş
yaparken Radyo başında dinliyorlar ama
ama İnternette şu anda ciddi bir ivme
var yani İnternetten dinleme oranları
gittikçe artıyor ve internetten
ulaştığımız için de Eskiden
bizim yurt dışında dinlenme imkanımız
yokken artık şimdi yurt dışında da çok
rahat dinleniyoruz Yani insanlar yurt
dışında yaşayan vatandaşlarımız
istedikleri saatte radyoyu açıyorlar ve
karşılarında bizi bulabiliyorlar böyle
bir imkana da sahip olmaya başladık Yani
aslında dijitalleşme ile beraber Radyo
ulaştığı ağ çok daha fazla
genişletti şimdi bir yandan da Tabii şu
var Evet böyle bir Ağa
ulaşıyoruz Peki radyo olarak ne
yapacağız Radyo bir müzik kutusu mu Bir
diğer
soru 30 sene oldu bu işe mesleğe
başlayalı Nihat sırdarla beraber
başladık Ve 30 senedir hep savunduğumuz
şey şu
oldu muhakkak içerik üretmek gerekiyor
bir müzik radyosu olmamalı bizim
savunduğumuz şey buydu şimdi son
yıllarda tamamen bu dediğimiz noktaya
gelmeye başladık
Neden Çünkü artık eğer müzik dinlemek
istiyorsanız ille bir radyoyu açmak
zorunda değilsiniz Elinizde bir uygulama
var İnternet var ki kaldı ki bir radyo
açtığınızda istemediğiniz bir şarkı denk
düşebilirsiniz Yani neden kendinizi
riske edesiniz veya bir reklamla hatta
uzun süren bir reklamla
karşılaşabilirsiniz neden bu olsun o
zaman ben giderim Spotify gibi bir
uygulamayı Apple müzik gibi bir
uygulamayı açarım kendimi bir liste
oluştururum risksiz tertemiz istediğim
şarkıyı da dinlerim O nedenle bizim en
başından beri savunduğumuz şey içerik
üretebilmek ve bakın radyoda içerik her
şeyden o kadar önemli ki radyoda program
yapan Dinlediğiniz radyocular varsa bir
düşünün ses tonları önemli
değil yani şu an isim vermeyeyim ama
çeşitli radyocular düşünün ses tonları
çok iyi mi değil ama önemli olan neden
çok dinleniyorlar Çünkü anlattıkları
içerik var ve dinleyiciyi çeken şey bu
içeriğin başına geliyor dinleyici ve
şimdilerde Podcast dediğimiz uygulamalar
var
aslında Podcast Evet hayatımıza girdi
bizim için
önemli Biz Radyo olarak Aslında
yıllardır yapıyorduk adı Podcast iyi
bizim için yani biz yapmış olduğumuz
yayınların tekrarını veriyorduk
koyuyorduk internete Biz diyorduk ki
yayının tekrarını dinlemek istiyorsanız
internetten dinleyin sonradan adı bunun
Podcast oldu ve Podcast üzerinden
insanlar dinlemeye ve ulaşmaya
başladılar dediğim gibi bizim için
burada önem olan şey içerik bu radyoda
da geçerli televizyonda da geçerli Veya
Bu internette de geçerli Öyle değil mi
düşünün Ne izliyorsunuz ne dinliyorsunuz
niye takip ediyorsunuz Önemli olan
anlatılan şey sizin için bana bir şey
veriyor mu beklentiler var burada bilgi
almak istiyor olabilirsiniz haber almak
istiyor olabilirsiniz eğlenmek istiyor
olabilirsiniz burada önemli olan şey bu
bir başka konuya
geçeceğim Haber ben çok uzun süredir
haber program yapıyorum
Eee ve Bence bu
dönemin Belki de 5 10 senedir ama
Önümüzdeki yılların da en önemli
meselelerinden bir tanesi dezenformasyon
olacak Şu anda da içinde bulunduğumuz
dönemde olduğu
gibi şimdi bir haber görüyoruz ben bunu
çok
yaşıyorum sosyal medyada biri bir şey
yazıyor hemen arkasından Herkes o haber
doğruymuş gibi devam ediyor hiç kimse
araştırmıyor Hatta şöyle söyleyeyim
yayına bana mesaj atan oluyor diyor ki
bu Haber doğru mu acaba şimdi bu Haber
doğru mu acaba yazana kadar aslında
internete yazsa kontrol edebileceği
çeşitli alanlar var size söyleyeceğim
şey şu Her gördüğünüz ve duyduğunuz
habere her yazılana
inanmayın Bazen çok doğru geliyor ama
İnanın ki özellikle şu anda İletişim
çalışmaları yürütülüyor bu Türkiye'de de
var dünyada da var bakın Rusya Ukrayna
Savaşı yaşandı her iki taraftan farklı
açıklamalar geldi şu anda İsrail
Filistin gerilimi deniyor ama bayağı bir
savaş var ortada buradan gelen farklı
haberler var yani Haberlere bakarken
biraz kendi akıl süzgeci geçirmek
gerekiyor çünkü şu anda bu iletişimi çok
iyi kullanan ülkeler var bunu Radyo
üzerinden yapıyor sosyal medyadan
yapıyor televizyondan yapıyor bunlara
dezenformasyona bir defa çok dikkat
etmek gerekiyor bir haberi gördüğünüzde
Eğer aklınıza yatkın değilse yani
Örneğin bir metrobüs kazası olduğunda
burada yüzlerce yaralı var Binlerce kişi
yaralandı deniyorsa bir Düşünmeniz lazım
yani bir kazada o kadar kişi olabilir mi
olamaz
mı Dolayısıyla dezenformasyon mücadele
bizim için önemli bundan sonra radyonun
geleceğinde ne olabilir radyo nasıl
dinlenebilir bundan sonra gelecekte
bizim için
şu anda yapmış olduğumuz yayınlar gibi
radyoyu birçok kanaldan Örneğin
YouTube'dan da dinleyebilirsiniz hatta
YouTube'da bir avantajı var geri de
sarabiliyorum 7'de kalktım Nihat'ı
dinleyemedim Ama 7.30'a yola çıktım
7'den itibaren dinleyebileceğiniz
imkanımız olacak yani çeşitli televizyon
uygulamaları var ya platformlar var ya
yakında onun gibi olacak Çünkü aslında
doğrusu da bir yerde bu ha hiçbir zaman
canlı yayının karşılığını tutar mı
muhakkak tutmaz ama dediğim gibi eğer ki
doğru bir İçeriğe ulaşmak istiyorsanız
bilgiye ulaşmak istiyorsanız Bence o
bilgiye Siz istediğiniz anda ulaşabilmek
Evet bizim bir yayın akışımız var
herkesin yayına başladığı saat var ama
neden ben x kişiyi dinlemek istiyorsam
tam o saatte orada olayım Benim de bir
Konfor alanım olsun Ben belki 15 dakika
Belki 20 dakika sonra orada olacağım O
nedenle ileride radyoların da
Teknolojiye ayak uydurarak bu duruma
geleceğini Düşünüyorum
şimdi bize çokça sorulan sorulardan bir
tanesi kuruluşu Eee burada var mı kafa
Radyo dinleyenler var Oo süper harika
Hepiniz hoş geldiniz tekrar
Eee malum birkaç Eee radyoda çalıştıktan
sonra eee artık öyle bir dönem
içerisindeydim
ki başka bir radyoda çalışabilecek
imkanımız olmadı o imkan
tanınmadı tanınmadığı için de mecburen
Eee Biz de kendi radyomuzu kurmaya karar
verdik Radyo kurmak Eee böyle
çok basit bir şey değil çok büyük
maliyetleri olan şeyler fakat buna karar
verdikten sonra da malumunuz Nihat
sırdarla Candaş Tolga ışıkla birlikte
bir isim arayışına girdik ve kafa
dergisi o dönem hayatta olduğu için biz
de dedik ki o zaman kafa Radyo olarak
yolumuza devam
edelim başlangıç Fikri buydu Ama devamı
Tabii ki biraz önce size anlattığım gibi
içerikten geçiyordu yani kafa dergisini
nasıl bir içeriği var Tamamen yazılarla
dolu fikirlerle dolu aynı şekilde
radyonun da böyle olmasını istedik
Dolayısıyla kafa radyoda biz yola
çıkarken bizimle beraber o dönemden
bugüne devam eden arada isim
değişiklikleri yaptık ama dergide yazı
yazıp da yine radyomuzda program yapan
arkadaşlarımız oldu halen de devam
ediyor Yani netice
itibariyle kafa dergiyle kafa radyoyu
biraz bütünleştirmek istedik Ama
Türkiye'de şöyle bir dinleyici algısı
olduğu için tamamen 724 bir konuşma
olursa dinleyici biraz uzak kalıyor E ne
yaptık o zaman tabii ki araya şarkılar
serpiştirerek bu Yayınları size
ulaştırmaya gayret ettik ha bu Yayınları
şimdi böyle dinliyorsunuz Yani bizim
için bu şu
demek biz Denizli'ye bir verici
koyuyoruz
burada Denizli'de bir direk var antenler
var Buranın bir vericisi var Ve bunun
için yapılan bir yatırım var size sadece
denizliye ulaştırabilmek için bunu
yaptığımız gibi 50 merkeze daha bunu
yapıyoruz aynı anda şimdi bu bizim için
yani Radyo için maliyetli aynı zamanda
dinleyici için de bazen zor Şimdi şunu
sordum Dün Denizli'de yayınlar genelde
net bir problem yaşanmıyor diyorlar Bu
açıdan Sevindirici ama bazı problemler
oluyor yani bu parazit diye
nitelendirdiğimiz o cızırtılar denk
geliyorlar yakında Amerika'da başlayan
bir sistemden bahsedeceğim şu olacak
araçlar bize gelirken
üzerinde internet ve GSM hattıyla
gelecek Yani aracı Biz GSM hattı ile
beraber satın alabileceğiz böyle bir
imkan olacak şimdi biz internete
geçtiğimiz andan itibaren
araçta artık bizim de buraya bir verici
kurma ihtiyacımız verici direği için bir
yatırım yapma ihtiyacımız kalmayacak
Artık siz de gittiğiniz her yerde bizi
internet üzerinden internetin olduğu her
yerde kesintisiz bir şekilde
dinleyebileceğiniz ve bu radyonun daha
fazla dijitalleşmesi sebep olacak yani
aslına bakarsanız Bizim için en büyük
beklenti bu Evet başlangıçta Belki biraz
maliyetli olacak olabilir yani araçları
alırken maliyetli olacak olabilir Ama
bunun için mesela Amerika'da şunlar
yapılıyor araç alacaksınız diyorlar ki
size işte GSM mi yani internetli mi
internetsiz mi internetli paket
alırsanız size Şu kadar bir indirimimiz
jestimiz olacak diye ya Muhtemelen
Türkiye'de buna benzer şeyler olacak
Dolayısıyla Aracınıza bindiğinizde
Şehirden şehre geçtim oradan oraya
gittim Şu sokaktan bu sokağa döndüm
birden yayın kesildi yayın
parazitleniyor dinleyemiyorum sorunları
İnternet olduğu sürece bizim hayatımızda
artık
olmayacak gelecekte bizim beklentimiz
açık açıkçası radyodan bu iletişime
dönecek olursak tekrar iletişim
konusunda radyonun çok önemli bir mecra
olduğunu şuradan anlıyoruz radyoyu
dinleyenler için söylüyorum Reklamların
bolluğunun farkındasınızdır zaman zaman
dönem dönem Hatta şikayetler olur
Bununla ilgili ama radyonun tek geçim
kaynağı da reklamdır başka bir geçim
kaynağı yoktur radyonun Radyo önemli bir
iletişim aracı olmasa bu kadar kocaman
firmalar büyük firmalar radyolara reklam
vermezdi seçim dönemlerinde birçok
siyasi radyolara konuk olmak için
telefonla bizleri aramazdık O nedenle
Radyo önemli bir iletişim aracı olarak
kalmaya devam edecek hayatımızda Evet
televizyon biraz daha görselle bizim
karşımıza çıkıyor Bizden çok daha
iddialı doğru ama tüm bunlarla beraber
unutmayın radyoyu Dinlediğiniz Deek
ortalama Böyle konuşan radyolar aşağı
yukarı bir saat bir 1 bu5 saat dinliyor
bir dinleyici bir seferde onun
içerisinde maruz kalacağı reklamı
tanıtımı propagandayı siz düşünün Yani
netice
itibariyle Radyo hiçbir zaman Ölmeyecek
Bizim için en çok Bizim de takip
ettiğimiz merak edilen sorunun cevabı bu
önümüzdeki yıllarda da dediğim gibi
sadece şekil değiştirerek Ulaştığınız
mecra değişerek radyo yayınları bir
yandan hayatına devam edecek Eee ben
buraya gelirken Denizli'ye gelirken e
Radyodaki arkadaşlarımızla Tabii çok
sıklıkla konuştuk Eee Denizli'deki
yayınlar da iyi olduğu için Denizli'den
de çok dinleyicim var O nedenle tüm E
kafa Radyo ailesinin ekibinin gerçekten
söylüyorum bunu teknik personeline kadar
herkesin sizlere de çok selamları var
Onların da selamları üzerimde kalmasın
hepiniz bir kez daha hoş geldiniz Sağ
olun
teşekkürler i